good morning believe nation today's
message is make something people want
over to you Sam startups to be
successful half the builds on many
people want if you get that right you
can get everything else wrong pretty
much if you get that wrong you can get
everything else perfect and we see this
all the time we see startups that hire
the best lawyer in the valley they get a
beautiful office they they work with
really great accountants and a great PR
firm they do everything that a start-up
means to do except build a product that
customers or users want and this is so
important this is this is probably the
most important people start up a device
in the early days this is the only thing
that matters you have to do this you can
ignore all the other advice you can
ignore all of the crazy stuff that
people do when they're trying to advise
you about a set of a company in fact you
should ignore most advice most are good
right that's terrible you should feel
free to ignore any with this to accept
this one thing if a start-up doesn't
make something the users want the
startup will never ever be successful
making something people want is
massively important and if you don't do
what your company will fail
but it's only half the equation you also
have to love what you're making this is
where you will have ultimate success as
an entrepreneur and it doesn't matter if
you've gone to university or Business
School or had a history with parents in
as entrepreneurs or any of that doesn't
matter this is the thing the most
important thing to understand and it's
easy anybody can pick it up you will
have success as an entrepreneur when you
make something that people want if
you're providing value and you love what
you do
these have to be intersected they have
to match when you can combine those two
things together you have a successful
business because look what happens when
the two things don't align if you're
making something that people want but
you don't love it you're never gonna put
in the work the effort the grind
to become the best because there's
somebody who will also make something
people want and does love it and they're
always going to crush you they're gonna
be putting in 16-hour days and just
dreaming about it every single day and
telling all their friends and trying to
find a ways to make it work and for you
you don't care enough about it because
you don't love it so that model is not
gonna work you may make a little bit of
money because you see an opportunity but
it's never gonna be the thing that will
help you take off it's never gonna be
the best version of you because you're
doing something that you're not
passionate about on the flip side if
you're doing something that you love but
is useless to other people even that
hobby it's great go out and do that
thing that you love but if you can't
find a way to add value to other
people's lives and make something that
they would actually pay for you don't
have a business either and so the
ultimate success comes when you can
combine those two things together you've
got the thing that adds value to
people's lives and that people really
want and you love doing it and as long
as those two things are in harmony then
you've got a massive successful business
like it changed the course of your life
and the people around you as well so the
question today today is I'm curious are
you making something that people
actually want are you there yet you're
getting great feedback yet
I'm curious leave in the comments below
and I'll join in discussion I also want
to give a quick shout out to Herman PIR
Herman thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word it
really really really means a lot to me
and I hope you're enjoying the me thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
they believe nation thank you so much
for watching if you want to learn more
about this subject get a little bit
deeper on it I'm gonna share some extra
bonus clips that I hope you'll enjoy
what's the single worst marketing
decision that you can make and I think
we've all been there it's that you start
with a crappy product but as marketers
this is what we do day in and day out
our job starts
when the product is finished but a
growth hacker says why why can't the
product be improved why does it have to
start what does it have to start so late
in the process why are weakening hand at
this final product when market feedback
would would incorporate into the product
product the elements that make it
successful and so when marketers stop
thinking of their job as to simply work
on what's already been done but to
answer these questions who is the
product for why would they use it why do
I use it marketing is baked into the
product so I love this quote from Paul
Graham the founder of Y Combinator he
says make stuff people want that's the
best marketing decision that you can
make and I think if you look at a
company like Instagram you see this very
clearly right Instagram launched as a
Foursquare competitor and called bourbon
it was a geolocation service and it had
a feature that allowed people to upload
photos and put filters on them it got a
little bit of traction but nothing
nothing truly profound and so they
decide they're going to zoom in on this
single feature they're gonna they're
gonna throw everything that they've done
out so far and they're they're gonna
rebrand his Instagram it launches I
think there's something like 25,000
downloads its first its first day and it
sells to Facebook a year later for a
billion dollars so you could argue that
this the best marketing decision that
Instagram made was changing from bourbon
to Instagram everything else was extra
everything else was window dressing the
mark the product was the marketing most
businesses are the same
whether you're selling energy products
over if any consumer products if it's
useful to people the rest is just
business so if you find something or
invent something that's really useful
at that point it's really common
whatever you're selling
process is not that different and our
processes may be a little bit different
because we really don't have MBA type
processing we basically common sense you
know we look at businesses really in a
simple way you make good stuff and you
solid instead of you know all the pipe
Awards which I totally don't understand
like brand awareness and brand equity
and
all the fancy terminologies people use
that they don't have thought we what we
did was they stood me simply stick to
fundamental which is they make a really
good product and eighty percent of
marketing is making a really good
product and then you go out there and if
people like it they agree with you then
they buy actually you'll find most of
the products that they say are good are
marginal
right most of the folks that come up
with products usually you have some kind
of a gimmick in other words gee let's
make it pink if it's for women let's
make you know what's his name famous
person endorses
products themselves are marginal and
then they say 100 it's a good product
well my question is do you use it if
you're gonna go out there and sell it
you use it yourself did your family use
it and if they don't why are you selling
so really you're fine most of the fellas
that say we have great products we
didn't get success if they really don't
use the product they think everybody
else should not us we're superior to our
own product so there's there's a
compromise amongst people about the
quality of what they sell and quality is
also misunderstood
in other words quality starts with the
customer doesn't need it it doesn't
provide something you know that they're
gonna pay for
are we have different technical terms I
mean my are technical terms as planned
done you know everybody understands what
that is you got a slam-dunk product or
do you have a good product for us we get
pitched several products a week
if it's a good product we don't go out
there and sell it it's gotta be slammed
up it's gotta be where nobody will
refuse it and then you have a hard time
so the law is really they don't have the
products definition of a good product it
will do well now there's some amount of
execution but I would say that if you
don't have a great product
any amount of execution is going to only
buy you a little time after that
everybody will figure out this is not
that good and not buy it anymore